ah thank you so much everybody that was
a wonderful applause it really did make
me feel quite cool
uh yeah and i'm not honestly i'm not
really a cool
not really a cool fella in high school
too not really a big surprise i wasn't a
cool guy this girl
not a big hit in high school i'd go on
mom walks you know what i mean like
yeah that didn't vibe too well with the
football player cheerleader community
but you know it's okay i wasn't one of
the cool kids signing each other's
yearbooks with those uh sexy lady pens
and i'm talking about you turn upside
down and her dress falls off you know
like the cool
you know wearing a t-shirt with the
sleeves rolled up working on your
trans-am
bandana
untied shoelace i honestly don't have
any idea what cool is still
why what is it it's okay i wasn't high
school cool but you know what i was i
was camp cool
yeah
that's right summer camp
a place where a good attitude and
participation make you popular
i was like the fawns baby that was my
time to shine camp pete was like let the
cool kids have their summers mending
their lacrosse nets and learning how to
take off a bra with one hand
me
i'll be by the lake dutifully observing
the buddy system
that's more my jam while the cool kids
are off laminating their fake ids and
loitering in parking lots threatening
the elderly
i was improvising silly songs and
rocking friendship bracelets
on my ankle
you heard me ankle
can't beat wrote his own rule
and see that's the thing that was
considered cool at camp and ankle
friendship bracelet was cool and that's
what i learned from all of this
whatever you think is cool there's a
group of people who think that's cool
too
find those people that's one of the
things of life find them mine were
hiding at camp
by the lake
under a sunset singing a song with other
confident losers
trying to hit the high harmony free from
judgment
so find your own cool if you want to do
live action role play that's great find
a group of people who will call you
balkanox the magnificent it'll be fine
and if you want to take mdma and build a
mobile wooden tortoise run by solar
energy
burning man happens every year
find your cool me i'm still camp cool i
am still as a grown-up there's a
grown-up version of camp cool it's
basically just like a button-down denim
shirt cargo shorts a lot of vermont
tevas sipping on a kale smoothie
acoustic guitar strewn across my chest
i'm going bald but you know you grow it
long in the back
basically james taylor is what i'm
saying just picture
james taylor
the patron saint of camp cool